i think a documentary about going to
alaska is appropriate it's going to be
great
yeah i mean well i was doing gigs but uh
then yeah when we got out there i i
brought a videographer nicole our
producer of our podcast oh you did it
already yeah i was just there this
weekend i did uh i did wasilla which is
uh sarah palin's hometown i sent her a
dm as well as trigg no no responsibility
response unfortunately and uh
still waiting yeah still waiting he
liked ten pictures in a row
how was the game uh the gigs were good i
mean the one one show in wasilla was
like killer the first show i was like
oh that should be your special the
killer from priscilla
love that
love it
that would have been great god damn it
yeah
and then the second one was like it was
fun but it was a rowdy what you deem
like doc workers and alaska crowd where
i and afterwards i found out during the
show one guy told me that he was truly
on every drug known to man and then
afterwards he's like ah my old lady left
me today
are they like bars like big bars that
have stages or are they actual clubs
the the one in wasilla was like a big
restaurant on this giant frozen lake
which with crazy picturesque mountains
which is like it was beautiful because
the town of anchorage almost looks like
it looks like detroit with a bob ross
painting behind it like it's truly gray
and disney and then an insane contrast
mountains where you're like how are
these two things existing in the same
place at once it's [ __ ] baffling and
then so those shows were great and then
we did uh choku charlie's in in
anchorage which i know has been like
that's where the comics that i i think
big j used to play there a lot i've
known a lot of comics that have gone
through there and it's like rowdy and
and you know everything that you kind of
expect out of that sure and that was
that lived up to the hype the shows were
killer i got sexually assaulted by an 87
year old named wanda who works at the
birdcage bar like choku charlie's has
eleven it's by the way that explains
that that explains where the angela
lansbury joke came from earlier today
it's just top of mind exactly
because they have 11 rooms in this bar
like 11 different bars so you could like
truly
embarrass your family in three of those
bars and then still have a brand new
night ahead of you wow
eight other venues under the same story
it's like the it is the bar of anger it
felt like skankfest alaska that's that's
truly what it felt like and then this
woman wanda who has been like
birdcage was like out you know whatever
miles and miles outside of anchorage at
first and then they brought it in once
that place inevitably burned down via
you know some sort of debacle but she
was like
old as [ __ ] vacant-eyed but you have you
know it's a tradition amongst the
performers to
to uh staple your underwear to the
ceiling of her bar so they told me i'd
just go down i'd keep my pants on like
cut down the side of my underwear and
then whip it off in some sort of frenzy
and that would be it and it'd be kind of
fun she
blackout drunk forced me at like at just
face point to pull down my pants
pull down my underwear i'm in the middle
of this bar while my camera person who i
you know know but is a female and we're
staying on the road together for the
first time separate rooms but she's like
yeah for sure
[Laughter]
mike i'm sorry i'm sorry to let you know
this yes you were gaslit yeah
i really was i probably could have said
no
i just had to live up to the this is
what everyone does mike
so you liked it no i didn't so far in
eight minutes you've done nothing to
make me want to go
[Laughter]
how long was the fight
18 hours
[Laughter]
no it's a true nightmare the the flight
out there was like one of the worst
experiences of my life and then this guy
i sat like it's worse because i have to
piss constantly this guy who's my size
who i'm six one one eighty five i'm not
like i'm like huge but i'm a man and
this guy who is my size just
sat in the middle arms out like he's
that you know boxing out from a free
throw legs spread and i i'm like going
to sit down i'm like hey buddy you can't
lay and he's like i don't know what to
tell you and i go i know what to tell
you get the [ __ ] out of my seat right
now before there's an actual problem oh
did you say that i
snapped i
it's my 75th connection and i'm ready to
get united toss off this [ __ ] flight
i'm not wearing underwear
this was on the way there this is going
to be in new york city
i don't know what to tell you yeah he
said i don't know what to tell you and i
go i know what to tell you and i just
like i legitimately stayed in dennis
rodman position the entire [ __ ]
flight because any time i like i
legitimately like move down to pick a
plug and he's in my spot and so i just
would routinely just [ __ ] toss them
off because i was like dude we can step
off this plane and then have at it i
don't think there's any laws in alaska
let's [ __ ] absolutely throw down in
the lobby of the anchorage airport i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm on i'm on no
flight i fighting is on the tip of my
knuckles at all times anyway i'm always
willing to lose so this guy just caught
me at the proper point and he was a
[ __ ] he did just a [ __ ] about it he was
a jerk officer yeah he was a real jerk
he was just still ready to fight him
yeah right now you're still ready i am
ready to go yeah i actually just brought
myself back it's between that and the
sexual assault that's really rattling my
feathers because the 87 year old i don't
know if you've ever had this happen but
she was
pulling as i'm as i'm holding like my
balls and dick to try i didn't care if
any woman saw my dick but there was like
a group of 22 year old men from alaska
that i was like not a chance i'm giving
you the ammo to see what i got cooking
here especially under duress
nightmare like phones everywhere like
this isn't well
what did the guy say when you said that
to him uh the woman the guy who [ __ ]
you sat next to him
he was just he didn't say anything for
the rest of the flight which i found to
be weird but it moved but he moved but
then would move back as soon as i'd
shift weight and so this was like
an unspoken
fury for like five hours on the second
leg of a third leg trip and it's just
like and all these delays were happening
so you know and the alaska pilots stru
they striked so it didn't look like we
were gonna even come home and then we
got put on these other flights it was
like it was kind of just a perfect storm
of [ __ ] but i will say once we got there
the people at the gigs were fantastic
were you late arriving no no i mean well
i was later than i would have been but i
arrived at like
1 30 a.m as opposed to 12 30 a.m oh okay
but it's still about four hours dude the
three hours to la
it's [ __ ] up but like three hours to
la from where no the three hour
difference i'm sorry in time like that
that [ __ ] me up a little bit but for
the most part i can kind of do it that
extra hour the four hours alaska
difference to new york difference pulled
me under the earth on several occasions
like i have never felt that physically
[ __ ] in a while what do you do you fly
to la it's say five hours and then five
and a half hours then what is it like
five hours to elastic so that's what i
bet people of a higher uh tier fame
would get but i flew out to chicago flew
out to seattle and then flew down
seattle yeah i mean it was just not a
well-rounded plan the way home was much
much better it was alaska to denver to
new york which that's that's reasonable
and it was completely seamless but the
way out was yeah it was a bit bit much
the one thing i do want to say is that
wanda the blank-faced lovely woman who
worked at the bird cage in alaska she
was pulling at my happy trail
as i was holding my [ __ ] and my pants
were at my ankles with my underwear and
i'm trying to shimmy out of them and
then she's like all right you gotta lift
it up there and staple it up and i was
like i'm not letting go of my shirt and
balls i'm not certain balls yeah i'm not
lifting up and winning the pooing it so
my little piglet just [ __ ] dangles
and these 22 year old real men point to
what a lady i am sweet right no that
makes sense you made the right question
i didn't want them to gaslight me
it would have actually just been true
sure like that's what's inside i just
put i put the underwear on the staple
gun and i held my nuts and stapled it up
like that right they probably thought
you were a real man after that that's
right it's an awful tradition yeah this
is the tradition should not spray it
they're so excited that was after two
shows my bag was swamps oh wait this is
the tradition this is what they they're
like you have to do it's a tradition
mine was the only underwear up there but
it is
[Music]
honestly like as you're telling that
story half of me is like oh poor mike
and the other half of me is like why
didn't i have hot dog make a vlog at
wrestlemania with me i mean that's what
you got so stupid he was there i got him
to film other stuff he didn't do a vlog
did you or did you fly around in alaska
or do you drive around in alaska so
that's that was the weird part is
initially we get there and i'm like
we're going to see moose we're going to
see mountains like all this [ __ ] but
we're in anchorage and the only ride
that we had out was to wasilla and back
so i was like are we just kind of
moseying around with like all these
homeless genghis khans threatening to
[ __ ] stab us at every corner because
it is also like kind of a terrifying
situation is it really yeah and then on
the last day because we our flight got
bumped to about i think 11 p.m alaska
time so
late that the last day they took us for
that ride where we got to see all these
mountains went to a bunch of nature
still not a [ __ ] moose in sight but
we saw several bald eagles which was
pretty cool but uh yeah it was it was
incredibly beautiful do you feel like
you're in america
yeah i mean i feel like i'm in america
anywhere i go that's right you bring you
bring the stars and strikes with you
that they gave me as a crowd
is a big city or small um it seems small
but again i was kind of relegated to a
corner of it so i don't know if i saw
everything the food is crazy like that's
why i have
yeah i have quagmire face right now like
i am just wildly bloated from fried
foods and just crazy meats
reindeer sausage was pretty damn sweet
that's what i had that concept that
sounds good yeah it actually was tasty
they did have some moose and yak i uh i
think we dabbled in yak did not find any
moose wow i didn't see they were like
moose are like pigeons you're gonna bump
into one walking out of a door and i'm
like all right we didn't see a single
[ __ ] moose while i was like [ __ ]
were you in a nice hotel yeah we were in
a haunted hotel in the historic
anchorage hotel where uh apparently
there's a dead cop that got shot during
the bootlegging days out in the lobby
and then they dragged him into the lobby
just so he could bleed out inside wow
and uh then there's like a couple other
damsels in distress
this sounds fun at all
it's that like your entire your entire
story your entire trip has been like the
trip was great and then a list of things
why the trip was not great i don't think
alaska's tourists it sounds hard to hear
you yeah i think you guys just don't
know what to look for i hate the
anchorage hotel i'm looking at it stinks
i want a nice hotel is there a ritz yeah
i mean
jim doesn't stay at haunted hotels
anymore not the last one he says his
teeth are dry
i'm a bourdain type traveler where if i
go to alaska
but i want to do what the locals are
doing i'll snort a nice rail right off a
blade
that's a small room with two beds i hate
the [ __ ] thing at the bottom of the
bed yeah i know i hate that yeah oh
they're little rollies because it sucks
and you have to touch it good for
propping up your phone when you're
looking at porn though i guess so but
it's fake class and so i take that and
throw it on the floor because i don't
wash that yeah you see i feel like i
feel like you asked the wrong questions
like i feel like
mike and i would have the same def is it
a nice hotel yeah it's pretty nice but
that's not your nice home no my nice
hotel is not with [ __ ] uh
pillows i'm with jim on this one i want
a gentleman gentlemen's accommodations
yes
there's no bugs there's no bugs or
anything yeah it's pretty nice this is
like watching an episode of roseanne to
me
the lighting of roseanne depressed my
whole depression my whole life i see
this i go this
of the couches inside the room go back
to that picture of that [ __ ] couch that
is [ __ ]
that is [ __ ] yeah and that amount of
pattern that very very complicated
pattern while probably very expensive is
actually done to hide dirt
yeah yeah this is this is probably
really expensive though
in the lobby they had a chess board and
i put out the white pawn in two spots to
see if a ghost would challenge me to a
game and uh once i got there i was like
oh my god the piece is back and the guy
at the front desk was like yeah i put it
back
i was like oh all right you thought you
had an experience with
a ghost waiting for a real chestnut to
take a minute
well uh you're gonna be able to you're
gonna drop the dock on your youtube
channel yeah that'll event you know
patreon first so if you if you want to
pay for it you can but it'll be out for
free eventually horrible yeah
come out to the crowd work special 4 20.
that'll be funny yeah that'll be very
fun we're gonna have some guests i think
i'm gonna put a beanbag chair up on the
stage so if i feel like nodding out for
a half hour talk amongst yourselves yes
new york comedy club 420 the uh
mike cannon crowd work on edibles
special it's gonna be great content be
there live for it if you're here in new
york go to mikecanoncomedy.com
at i am mike cannon and of course uh
jared freed the podcast is you up with
uh jordana abraham um you can go to
jaytrain56 on twitter jaredfried on
instagram jaredfree.com you'll be able
to see him at the comedy works in denver
april 21st through the 23rd then on to
the funny bone in columbus uh new jersey
performing arts center in newark madison
wisconsin tampa
can't thank you enough for having me
yeah
good to see you
good to see you thank you guys so much
anytime man truly really nice i
appreciate it